that's right it is time for drew's news
if you're the dog we're your good news
bones
that's right and with me at the desk
proud parent to three chihuahuas rossi
rossman that's right hi everybody hi
over there hi
you are a proud dog a proud dog owner
very proud doggy daddy yeah you are
um i am really excited for the movie
that everybody is talking about right
now it's don't look up
it's the
juggernaut directed by adam mckay it has
jennifer lawrence leonardo dicaprio
meryl streep
jonah hill
it is all the rage and they're on the
press circuit right now and i found out
a really fun fact that i wanted to share
with you
pop sugar reports that apparently jonah
got in trouble
for bringing along a fart machine what
um
i like already love jonah but this makes
me love him a lot more
so everyone was like oh but meryl streep
is there for us of course she's there
for and jonah you are a hero for the
fart community thank you for standing up
i there's nothing funnier i'm sorry
until i'm 90 years old nothing will be
funnier than a [ __ ] and someone has to
toot their own tutor good for you
well apparently netflix has formally
asked jonah to maybe stop with the farts
but jonah said that he will not stop
with the farts
also i love his whole new surfer vibe
like it's so good and i'm just so happy
for him what an extraordinary career
that he has um you know really written
for himself and he's just getting
started martin scorsese is going to
direct him in a um
grateful dead uh jerry garcia movie
right now i didn't hear about that
that's happening soon and then did you
see him and his girlfriend on that wind
in the same gucci suit i know he's been
nominated for two academy awards i mean
he came up as a young comedic actor and
here he is
rewriting the book on what a male movie
star can do he writes his own parts he's
just so talented
and he brings a fart machine i love him
you win jonah hill you win you win
someone else who wins taylor swift loves
to break a record and here is the latest
her new 10-minute version of all too
well have you all heard that she's
saying it on snl
well jake gyllenhaal has heard that yes
he has yeah he heard that well it just
hit number one on the charts making
it but it is now officially drew the
longest song to ever be number one on
the charts clocked in 10 minutes i
really love it i really i love the first
six minutes because that's all as far as
i got girl 10 minute song i got a job
who can who has time to say let's
attempt but isn't there like another
song that was long also because
i think
she surpassed that well the original one
american pie but don mclean you know
that song that song was like eight and a
half minutes long or something like that
and hers is ten so she surpassed him and
then what happened well she sent him
flowers and said i'll never forget that
i'm standing on the shoulders of giants
your music has been so important to me
taylor swift
she's such a classic
i love it she did that
i love it
that's the power of songwriting and
music it can bring us all together okay
next up we have got the party i want to
throw for myself when i turn 90.
the week my very favorite magazine
reports that pat moore had a retired
navy and air force veteran celebrated
his 90th by jumping out of a plane nine
times nine times what
one jump
for each decade of his amazing life and
other skydivers joined him and they
raised 16 000 for the international
skydiving museum rossi yes thoughts well
first have you ever gone skydiving i
have that's me look at you
here's what nobody tells you about
skydiving
no one tells you
that they're going to shove
like a leaf blower in your face yeah
around my mouth and putting oh wait
i went skydiving and there i am and so i
will see your leaf blower in the mouth
and i will raise you
one chin folded back over the other chin
on my face and i think that um
everyone should skydive one time yeah
one time but if if you started doing
more than that now it's just on you girl
it's on you
you you skydived yes i did what's your
name barb barbara did you have the leaf
blower syndrome too no yes i did i was
by myself though i didn't do the
tannin
you didn't
for the first time yeah
bar oh my god
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you might be the bravest person i've
ever met well it was just one of those
things that i was 40 years old when i
did it i'm a little older now
and um yeah i did it one time i wouldn't
do it again but it was so much fun okay
barbara what was the last thing you told
yourself by yourself jumping out of an
airplane for the first time hoping for
the best what'd you say to yourself
can i say it on air yeah just roll with
it
[Applause]
thank you barb
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you what barb said i love you oh
my god thank you so much wow barb i love
you all right
well
finally you know we're smack in the
middle of the holiday feasting season
are y'all eating a little extra yeah i
know oh my god i have literally
developed like a tire around my stomach
a holiday tire
yeah
you know tis the season well if you're
enjoying all the holiday treats but
you're looking for a little balance
we've got the workout for you the sydney
morning herald reports the step routines
you know the thing where you step on the
little step well it is making a comeback
this sweaty fast-paced cardio workout
that jane fonda helped make famous
member is popping up at gyms everywhere
check this woman out on tick tock ariana
she spent the last year working on an 80
step workout she called shuffling okay
this looks nothing like the step
aerobics that i'm used to
this is the running man
mixed with like jazzercise and tick tock
should we try
the step aerobics i'm used to was like
this
up
and back and up well and back
that's it that was step aerobic and you
would do that
and you would get so into it oh i'm into
it look i brought sweatpants full blown
dancing look at this and i got this
holiday sweatman
so what is she doing again show me yours
come on girl
what is she doing she's like
[Applause]
um
you know what as long as we're dancing
and moving that's all i care about thank
you
all right we're gonna go to commercials
[Music]